it has been more than a week since
13-year old Jamie cloths disappeared in
Wisconsin when her parents were found
dead in their home investigators are now
asking the public to help find two
vehicles of interest in this case the
Barron County sheriff said yesterday the
vehicles were spotted on surveillance
video near the home they're described as
a red or orange Dodge Challenger in a
black Ford Edge or an Acura MDX Don
Dahler is outside the Sheriff's
Department in Barron Wisconsin Don I
know everybody's thinking good thoughts
for Jamie Claus at this time good
morning to you yeah exactly good morning
the sheriff is asking for any
information about those vehicles but
he's also asking for volunteers about
2,000 people are expected to join the
search for Jamie cloths today that's
almost half the population of this small
town that after hundreds turned out last
night for a gathering of hope
[Music]
the small community of barren Wisconsin
came together at a high school football
stadium Monday night not for a game but
to pray for 13 year old Jamie causes
safe return we all have the same goal in
mind and that is to bring Jamie home and
back into our arms
Jamie was last seen October 14th at a
family member's birthday party early the
next morning a garbled 911 call was made
from her mother's cell phone when police
arrived at the klas home about four
minutes later they say Jamie was gone
and her parents were found dead I asked
him I said are those gunshots in an
interview with Daily Mail Comm neighbors
of the Cloths family said they heard two
gunshots about 20 minutes before the 911
call was made they thought it was a
hunter in the area it makes us feel bad
is because we didn't call him right away
that maybe we could have saved her we
received over 1,300 tips in our
community and from across the nation we
have closed 1,100 of those Barron County
Sheriff Chris Fitzgerald said because of
tips they received investigators are
expanding the ground search he asked for
two thousand volunteers to come out
Tuesday to walk specific areas we are
looking for anything that may be related
to the incident I'm terrified I'm I want
to stay in my home where I know that I'm
safe that I can keep my baby safe with
few leads people in the community are
staying alert and are desperate for
Jamie to be found
we just want answers you know I don't
know we want to come home safe
the sheriff is also asking for people to
walk their properties around here check
their hunting cabins that sort of thing
for anything suspicious he said
investigators still believe that Jamie
is in danger and they have not ruled out
any scenarios Nora all right John thank
you